[Music]
the a7 pawn at the right moment yeah we
i think a car is waiting for that he
watched that match for sure yesterday
and but you can't just check now that's
oh wait what do your car just do
he's gonna get flagged here oh my gosh
he tricked him and and olivia's trying
to win on the clock
[Music]
wait all he needs is a draw
but it's hard to
force it
i know here goes the b bar
oh my god
oh my six is good
it should be five
oh
okay this is 92 chapter knighted to
check knight to check you check and you
win three oh he didn't see it
the check was there oh but he's found
he's found nine of three no but bishop
two six and now knight of three rookie
two
no bishop takes f3
doesn't help
oh my god
is getting ascended over time
no he's gonna win it he's gonna win it
yeah he wins it he wins it
oh god this is insane man this is insane
thank god
what a performance by the youngster and
queen d3 check just for good measure
check here's a taking c4 check that is
extreme precision he didn't have to but
he did that's all he reserved and he
wins the queen i mean the guy is just on
another level
[Music]
and there it is there it is he throws it
in
he's not 10 more than 10 seconds this is
he should be four oh oh yeah but should
be four at that moment and now and now
he plays it
oh but look at that move throwing in the
check just to gain some time this is
actually expert bullet oh the hooks the
rocks oh and he had the match he had the
tie but he lost his rookies lose all of
his pawns he just has to take the pawn
that's it that's the match that's it
kikaru
you can't pre-move there oh he had that
game and ali raised a farouza for the
second day in a row he wins because of
this sneaky little take something
pre-move winning the game and that is
that ali riza faruja smiles he works his
way to the finals of the bullet chess
championship and he will face andrew
tanks yes okay now that the king's cut
off danny
just cut off that means
forks
like a fork in maniac
oh my gosh
oh the fork paint is real
and uh again you could smell it right
you started talking about he cut the
king off like we didn't know how it was
going to happen but no surprise that
no but it's not enough time he could
have just taken g7 and bishop d5 that
was a bluff
okay i guess you're just so tricky
yeah
this should be enough and just
absolutely
almost one second
he's seven swollen rook d7
you literally almost just lost on time
living off the increment ali reza is but
the pin is really telling here danny
king b3 king b3 knight d5 he's running
out of time oh my gosh oliver flagged
him
oh that is painful that was a game white
had no business winning oh man
he had no business winning that game
here it's a win
i i guess
yeah because there's just too many pawns
uh-oh i guess it's so it's a win uh-oh
bishop wait he messed up he messed up
very good
he's still probably winning
he will deflect the bishop with the f
pawn then take the a3
yeah
not with this plane he's not yeah bring
the king to e4 push f4
probably he's winning here
yeah there's still too many weaknesses
for for white yeah yeah yeah also there
is this plan of pushing it to uh pushing
the f1 yeah you could even play three
and three f2 and you win
there's a reason we have the omg's or
snaps emote
we should not find and it was not knight
d5 stick around to find out what it was
this move is a trade offering of both d6
and b5 for b6 unfortunately for geary
that's too little too late he takes on
b6 but gives a b5 in the process as we
see in the background max and magnus
decides to step up and get his stretch
on in the process here comes rook to ca
check and on king to c7 we see that
white is not only about to lose a6 but
that advancing the d-pawn also doesn't
work with black's double protection over
the square black finds the move brook to
c5 and after bishop takes a6 d7 but here
comes rook to b7 too many pieces are
being attacked it's too late for geary
rook to c6 guards the knight bishop to
b5 rook d6 takes advantage of the fact
that the knight can't take because of a
queen but it's just fancy tricks because
rook b8 over protects everything and
after the move rook d5 brook takes b6
anish geary realizes he has nothing left
but a two-piece disadvantage and at most
he can just get one of them back
it's a very good uh
teamwork oh it's a draw oh my god
it's some kind of a kasparov game you
know this caspar yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
evergreen and stuff 12 seconds
you cannot defend this with black in
this time it's just for sure just
somehow wins this game
what is he doing what is it why did he
allow the king back in king was like
no idea what's going on 36 seconds man
36 seconds he needs to just drag it out
and not lose
oh he's actually losing control of the
position he's losing he's losing his
queen
and he's he's in time he's also in time
he doesn't know yesterday oh my god oh
my epic epic
this is brilliant
this is insane
the players have to rematch let's go
here we go
holy crap dude this is insane man if he
wins this game all federal save had to
do was take the draw
[Music]
you